hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
today's video is about phase
you may have heard that term before um
even if you have hopefully this will be
a fresh take on it because there's
clearly a lot of misunderstanding on
what it is
and what it means as far as audibility
um the idea for this video actually came
from a viewer
that pointed to this youtube video from
paul mcgowan from ps audio who's uh
does even though the ceo of the company
does these uh
frequent videos and different technical
topics and the technical topic that
uh was sent to him was if we can only
hear
20 to 20 kilohertz why is it that
companies advertise and build equipment
that goes to 70 80 100 kilohertz
or even higher and uh
paul uh did a short video which you can
see in here i'm not going to play
it just in case he complains
where he doesn't actually answer the
question of why you need
a white bandwidth but he says that if
you don't have white bandwidth
you will get what is called the phase
shift and that that phase shift
is audible and uh just like a lot of
things in
in high-end audio there's an element of
truth in an argument
and is run with that uh hoping that you
know less than the presenter
and that you buy the answer
so what he says is indeed true that
if you take any system and apply a
filter to it then any system that
doesn't have unlimited bandwidth
by definitions filtering things so take
an amplifier that only goes to 100
kilohertz then rolls off
as it rolls off the frequency response
changes but also the phase changes
so um i thought i'd show you that in in
an actual uh demonstration of my audio
precision so
what i have hooked up to my audio
precision is a simple thing
one channel is just going from input to
output so the audio precision is
measuring itself
the next the other channels going
through this little boxes from isomax's
isolator for
interconnects signals and
i'm going to be reviewing this soon but
for this purpose don't worry about what
this box does
suffice it to say that it has limited
bandwidth it
doesn't have unlimited bandwidth so i've
got it going through the audio precision
right now and let me bring up the
ap myself uh so i know what i'm looking
at so
what you're seeing here is is the sine
wave i've told it to be the sine wave at
one kilohertz
thousand hertz so you see the sine wave
in here and the two waves are more or
less the same the one that's going
directly
through the analyzer and the other one
that's going through the transformer
that's in this thing
there's a little bit of voltage loss
because there's losses in
in any device like this and but
otherwise things look the same don't
worry about the distortions it creates
that will be in the review so what i did
was that though i run a frequency
response sweep
and uh let me first show you the
frequency response the one channel
that goes through the analyzer from one
side one side to the other
the audio precision has extremely wide
bandwidth and you can see that is
flat response the one that goes through
the
isomax isolator naturally has a filter
effect and it does indeed roll off the
frequency response
uh and by the time you get to 56 kilos
you're down fair amount
and uh if we ask the audio precision to
also plot the uh
phase shift uh the one channel that's
going through is obviously has no
phase shift but the second channel the
one that's going through the transformer
we see that gradually the one signal is
departing from the other one from timing
point of view and we can actually go
back and see that a thousand hertz there
wasn't much of a departure but if i
make this 30 kilohertz uh
now look at what happened in here one
one
waveform is actually shifted in time and
that's
what phased well phase tells you where
this waveform is relative to any
reference point
and clearly these two don't have the
same reference point so one is further
and the other one or behind the other
one
for this purpose doesn't matter which
one is which but you clearly see the
phase shift in here and if i have
instead of 30 kilos if i go to 40
kilohertz we see that the phase shift
gets even larger the amplitude is
getting reduced because
it's rolling off the response so
hopefully
at this point you've got a good grasp of
what phase is is basically a shifting a
timing change in the signal but the
signal itself is otherwise
kept the same if you look down here the
frequency is still 40 kilohertz whether
i go through the box or not
so it's a linear transformation of
timing changes
in there so paul in his video he uses
his hand and
shows that graph that i just showed you
and said look because this phase shift
happens
that's bad and why is it bad he said the
human ear is very sensitive to that
wonderful where's the reference to that
no references provided
no research no control testing nothing
in paul's video and uh as eloquent as he
is in his videos with just
you know playing speaking he never ever
gives you rose references and you should
always be on guard
especially be on guard when somebody
tells you how the human hearing works
when their job isn't knowing how human
hearing works
paul is designs electronics and
designing electronics teaches you
nothing about audibility of face
you'll know what causes phase shifts and
he does but
you know if you want to know whether
something causes impairments we need to
go to the experts to test this kind of
thing and understand the
nature of phase shift and and what it
means so
let's uh let me uh cut this off and uh
let's go to uh uh some other information
out
for you so the probably the foremost
most
famous uh audio researcher we have is uh
dr floyd toole
his book is just the bible on on sound
reproduction in rooms and speakers and
what have you
um and he addresses phase in billion
different ways
and many uses of it but when it gets to
you know whether phase shift matters or
not
specifically in context of speaker
designs because it's crossovers are
filters and therefore
they introduce those kinds of phase
shifts uh something paul's not paying
attention to so
you know that speaker has a limited uh
response so it has also got phase shifts
so
whether your amplifier has phase shift
or not it's really secondary to all the
filters that are in your
but in the context of speaker design dr
floyd two
addresses all the previous research and
his own experience
that basically if even i've highlighted
for you
there's says and it shows you all these
research references
in that the music products through dance
loudspeakers in a normally reflective
room which all of our rooms are
reflective
you don't go listen in an anechoic
chamber um
you're in reflective room face
distortion is substantially completely
inaudible let me repeat you cannot hear
this phase shift
and i'll show you a simple reason why
that's the case
but this comes from control testing
um he references the uh this paper from
lipschitz
uh professor lipschitz and vanderkui um
i have that for you here and they did a
this is a journal paper so it's
technical it goes through lots of math
and what have you
but at the end it actually goes through
a controlled listening test
with headphones and speakers in anechoic
chamber and
normal rooms in anechoic chamber
and with headphones it is possible with
specialized test signals
that are revealing to detect the
difference not necessarily have a
preference for one or the other
but you can hear it but the moment you
go in a room
that has the moment you play music
and go in and or listen to it in a room
all bets are off and he clearly states
that
is that there's basically no effect and
even if there is an effect
it's going to be extremely subtle and
again i'll show you in a second what
that's the case so the research
tells you that this is not a concern
if it were a concern again all those
crossovers and all those phase shifts in
them and everything would be
you know huge problem and uh but
let's see if we can reason through this
ourselves
i have a ravel c52 speaker that i own
personally that i measured as one of the
first speakers i measured
this is sitting over here as on top of
clip hole near field scanner that i use
to measure it
and you can see the measurement
microphone from clippable system up here
um when we measure this speaker we see
this familiar
uh waveform in here um we see that you
know it rolls off the road low
frequencies and that is an excellently
designed speaker so it has very good
flat
almost flat uh frequency response on
axis
so things are nice and great but look at
what happens when i
measure the same speaker identical
speaker
in a room with a microphone and
this is an article that i wrote long
time ago for white screen review i'll
put a link in it on
what reflections in the room mean and
how perceptual they are
but this is it's frequency response now
when i measure it in a room
what the heck happened to that 30 graph
that we just looked at
does not exist why does it not exist
well what is the microphone here and
what do your ears hear
there's a direct sound that comes from
the speaker and
arrives at you instantly but meanwhile
that same sound from speaker also
bounces off every surface in your room
and
comes in and mixes with that on-axis
sound
just a few milliseconds later so at all
times what you're hearing
is a phase soup as we call it in that
every
uh waveform when it changes length
it adds delay and if you add delay it
changes the phase of the
signal when these things mix up together
you get all these cancellations and
additions
and as a result the response starts to
look like this these are all the sums
and
and all the vector sums we call in math
in that sometimes the things add
sometimes they subtract sometimes partly
act and it's not just one reflection you
have countless reflections in a room
all colliding with each other and
producing this complex waveform
fortunately your ear as you know from my
previous video does not have this kind
of resolution
so indeed if you filter that to what the
tonality would look like
you get this response for that speaker
which now looks very close to the
dynacoic response
which is a high frequency roll-off which
we naturally get in rooms because high
frequencies are
are more directional under surfaces in a
room that absorb it
so but but mathematically which is what
paul's going at is that oh there's this
phase in that you know simple phase that
i showed you on analyzer that just
gradual predicted smooth faces you want
to hear that you want that to not be
there and be perfect
when you're healthy in your room that's
just not
possible now you might say well that's
the room
well think about the live presentation
think about hearing
me talk if you were sitting next to me
there are reflections
everywhere all the time if you were
listening to me next to me
would you say that's a distorted thing
no because that's
live there's no recording there's no
application that's perfect right
but that perfect sound actually has a
completely
messed up phase information because of
all the reflections in a room
so when you listen to orchestral music
or any kind of music even if it's
amplified music is hitting all the walls
and
wherever the hall is that you're
listening to it so there's no such
thing as a echo-free room
and if there's no such thing as
echo-free room that means there's no
such thing as a pure
um phase transmission because if this
phase is gonna get
destroyed in in any situation now we've
been
you know evolutionary uh traits that we
have is that we've lived in caves and in
on on on earth and that they're always
been reflections and the brain has
gotten very good at filtering out a lot
of these reflections
and and the phase differences if it
hadn't yet go
nuts if you constantly your brain is
trying to analyze and listen to this
now this has nothing to do by the way
with phase discrimination between your
ears
that phase discrimination can actually
tell you what the direction is
but that's a differential phase of
what's different between your right ear
and left ear they're separated
in distances therefore they're separated
in time
and that allows you to triangulate
location of
of things together with volume
differential and frequency response
differential between your ears
but an amplifier is not doing that he's
saying if the amplifier response rolls
off
well if it rolls off he's doing the same
thing to both channels so therefore
there is no differential
phase that we're talking about so don't
get confused with people throwing
articles at you and saying oh we're very
very the hearing is amazing when it
comes to detecting face
it is for the difference in phase
between right here and left ear
not in absolute phase that's all we're
talking about in here
your amplifier is generating absolute
phase shift
and that absolute phase shift certainly
is not audible
uh you know in inaudible and we're
showing you
but the ultrasonic aspects it's just
even crazier
argument there but let's not go there
so now you might say well headphones how
about headphones headphones isolate the
room
assuming they're closed and so let's
look at that i
recently reviewed this audis lcd 24
headphone
and uh when we look at the frequency
response here
unlike speakers where i have that fancy
clippable near-field scanner
where it gets rid of all the room
reflections and gives you an acrylic
response we don't have that with
headphones
and basically we take the uh headphone
and put it on a fixture and
which simulates how your hearing works
and
when you have these cups around your ear
the sound comes out of these cups
and it's going to reflect inside this
cup it's going to reflect
against your face it's going to bounce
back and forth if there are
complex drivers in there it's going to
bounce back and forth internally in
those
so there's no such thing as echo-free
response there either and
indeed every one of my measurements
showed these kinds of
massive ups and downs especially as
frequencies get higher
and that's all caused by these
reflections adding and subtracting and
this by the way is a filtered response
if i didn't fully filter it
it'll be even worse and there are people
who show you these measurements with
extreme amount of filtering
and then you don't see that so don't be
misled by that you absolutely have phase
interference in here
and all of this cause interference now
it's not as bad as a room
that's why in research with special test
signals and with headphones
you can hear maybe detect certain amount
of
phase shift but again you don't have
you wouldn't as soon as the music plays
it's just so many instruments and so
much masking going on
that is simply is is not an issue
whatsoever
uh on this thing so
bringing this you know and by the way i
also have the phase response
in here look at what happens to the
phase measurements in here
there's a bunch of wiggle unless in here
that
you know who knows what the cause of
that is the ideal one would have an
exponential drop-off in here
and that would be a phase shift that
would be ideal headphone and still would
have a phase shift
in low frequencies in the middle in here
there's bunch of interference happening
that's what this soup is
that you see is because of that and then
these peaks up and downs are clear
cancellations
not all headphones are like this some of
them are much less
than this but they're all going to have
reflections and cancellations and so
forth
but it is less than the speaker so a
little bit more important so if you're
doing headphone listening
maybe it matters a little bit but
again there's no signs even to say that
you like it or don't like it if that
phase shift wasn't there it just says
that
with special signals you can barely
barely barely detect it
so bottom line phase
distortion and phase anomalies the
standard rule is
they do not matter remember that
a whole bunch of people want to scare
you into thinking they matter
well i'm selling you a cable it's got
less phase shift and everything
first thing is that they don't ever show
you the phase shift they just tell you
implied that there must be some shifting
in phase shift always insist on saying
all right then show it to me
let me see it then i could you know see
that it's even there that whether the
tweak that you're selling me
that actually improves phase shifts or
face performance
anyway you know they don't even do that
but be very
you know on guard you know paul has this
charming accent and
and styling youtube and you know he'd
make a great
uh fiction presenter when it comes to
audio know that he mixes
technical stuff he knows from designing
electronics
to immediately jumping into domains that
he has no experience whatsoever in
and it just tells you stories these are
really grandfatherly stories
that take them as entertainment i watch
some of these videos because it's just
charming to listen to them
and again half of it is there's some
truth in what he explains
but the other half as far as what his
stuff really means to you
it's just folklore the reality is that
if you have 200k
bandwidth it doesn't matter
whether you have 200 or 100 now there's
a right answer he could have given you
which is to have flat response to 20
kilohertz you may need to have 10 times
as much bandwidth
so that it doesn't roll off at 20
kilohertz any perceived
perceptual amount uh now most of us
don't hear 20 killers anyway so in
reality even if it
you know filtered off at 30 40 kilos
that'd be fine
uh by the way as soon as you play cd
that's 22 kilohertz hard limit anyway
so what happens after that doesn't
matter but yes there is some goodness in
an amplifier
that has wider bandwidth and sort of the
you know you just have that headroom and
good feeling about it
but uh beyond that there's no not much
value there people go build amplifiers
that one mega is bandwidth or more
and that's just asking for trouble it
can oscillate they can pick up am
stations and try to
play those things they can demodulate
them and then spit them out as actual
station itself
so you know as males we tend to think if
a little bit is good a lot is better
that's not the case without you just
know that you know we need
a fair amount of bandwidth but if your
source is limited to 20 kilohertz
22 kilos as the case with cd and
streaming and
all that is for 99 of what you listen to
you know we don't need that extra
bandwidth but if we do
you know let's go ahead and see the
measurements at least
paul mcgowan as far as i know his
company doesn't publish a single graph
like i've shown you
that demonstrates what the phase shift
really is anyway
they have a dac that has output
transformers it's a dst dac
i guarantee you that up up with
transformers do filtering and it's going
to show phase shifts so phase shift such
a bad thing
let's go ahead and see measurements of
that and and haven't uh proved to us
that it has no phase shift whatsoever
okay i better not uh keep ranting on
this thing so
uh remember phase is not something you
should worry about
and the only time you should worry about
if you fully understand what it means
and how it's used in the
conversation we're having and not
otherwise
okay hope you found this useful and uh
see you in a future video bye bye